son of a where'd you find a
steering wheel I didn't I had a frisbee
in the trunk and I taped it on that's
right I'm a Guyver the Donk out of this
thing and it worked flawlessly
actually I hit a ton of stuff on the way
over here it was awful of course you did
yeah Amy what up bro I need you to climb
back on that strongness ladder and I
need you to climb pretty high how high
remember that time we went to the deli
for cold cuts and the ticket machine was
broken so you found out what time
everyone arrived and made them getting a
single file line from earliest to latest
yeah higher copy that
you might want to stand back for this
sir it can get pretty intense
all right you moops our Union Health
Plan has 100 reimbursement for
out-of-state ambulance rides Scully will
fake a medical emergency don't need to
fake it always having at least one great
Yukon ambulance and have it take us here
to Monroe Louisiana the ambulance can
drive 25 miles over the posted speed
limit so we'll get there by 9 pm there's
a small airport there mostly servicing
crop dusters of course they can't take
passengers but thanks to a loophole in
HR 377551 police officers are allowed to
commandeer any plane in the interest of
National Security the crop duster will
land at an airstrip outside of Finksburg
Maryland we take a cab to Baltimore jump
on the 64 30 a.m trained to New York
arriving at 9 26 heaven will meet us at
Penn Station with a fresh Captain's
uniform from there it's a 29 minute cab
ride to One Police Plaza you change on
the way and we should get to your
meeting with five minutes to spare
[Applause]
stop clapping you idiots we gotta move
move hey lover
[Music]
welcome to the boil bus why are we
getting this whack ride Charles refuses
to accept what close friends we are he
thinks you're trying to escape and that
your crew's on the lookout for the Trans
Am So he insisted we switch into his
weird family bus that's ridiculous isn't
it doesn't matter what vehicle we're in
that's what I said I'm gonna escape from
you either way exactly wait what was
that I still don't understand what do
you mean you're escaping sorry bro
plan's already in motion Trudy came to
you you took the base come on if you
were really trying to escape why would
you tell me honestly I didn't like lying
to you you're a good friend well if I'm
such a good friend why are you trying to
escape from me I'm not trying to escape
from you I'm trying to escape from
prison let me ask you this do you know
why I stole that car because you love
doing crimes that's me directly quoting
your catchphrase first of all my
catchphrase is slurp slurp you've never
once said that I say it constantly
second of all mean loving crime is
classic empty bravado the truth is I was
arrested when I was 22 for something
stupid when I got out nobody would hire
me because I had a criminal record my
dreams of being a landscape architect
were out the window that was your dream
I wanted to be the black Edward since
that's great I get all that but that's
not what this is about I mean you could
have escaped from anyone but you chose
to set me up and now my job and my name
are all on the line you use me Doug
you're a bad friend you're the bad
friend I got you a track suit tigers and
tooks might as well be a jumpsuit a
prison jumpsuit you're taking me to
prison
there's a call for you oh is it a
casting agent from double deer I
submitted as a kid maybe they're finally
calling to put me on the show you think
they'd be calling 30 years later all
right fine I also submitted to the
reboot it's not double dare it's an
inmate from South Hill state prisons
Duty
hello hey Toronto well good hey Doug are
you okay I wanted you to know and I've
been thinking about it a lot I didn't
mean what I said I'm glad I met you sure
it ended badly but we had some good
times along the way too we went on a
cruise together we flew on Mark Cuban's
jet we ate at a restaurant next to Gail
from Top Chef yeah and then you got so
mad at her about Last Chance Kitchen I
wasn't mad I just think it's a saying
that they make you go online to watch it
the point is I wouldn't trade those
moments for anything I'm choosing to
focus on the journey
wait a minute what language is that I
don't know maybe Dutch there's a lot of
that in here you know how active the
Dutch Mafia is in Jersey Judy okay fine
surprise I'm in Amsterdam I escaped from
prison my wife and I are living a life
here now Amsterdam is great Jake they
got Universal Health Care legalized
marijuana and the workers are treated so
much better but you know what the best
part is that you're a free man again no
Stroop waffles they're like these wait
for cookies with caramel in between oh
yeah I think I've seen those at Trader
Joe's uh well look I guess I'm happy
that you're happy well I owe it all to
you what do you mean I think you know
what I mean uh nope no idea really
because after we hug goodbye I noticed
your pen was in my pocket oh that's
weird it was uh-huh and then I used it
to mind freak myself out of my cuffs and
then out of jail well then I guess it's
certainly lucky that it ended up in your
pocket I wonder how it got there yeah
I guess we'll never know
well however we get there I'm glad it
did
I love you Peralta
love you too Judy tigers and tooks
tigers and Dukes
I know how to solve this we just have to
find out which football player had third
period with random Bliss we need his
class schedule yeah but where are we
gonna find that in the coolest room in
the school
[Music]
you could have just picked the lock I
know I'm sorry I'm just so amped up
about admin the precinct will not be
shut down they decided to shut down the
7-4 instead wait I don't understand
apparently the community came to our a
there was a swell of online support
orchestrated by an organization called
gynazone I think you mean Gina Zone
I was behind the bar the whole time
another great Gina linetti entrance I
told you you can't be back here and I
told you I already am what did you do I
was live streaming a prank when Captain
Holt made his big speech about how you
did the right thing for the city I guess
people were moved they were like what
can we do to help and I said call the
Commissioner's Office the G Hive is real
I can't believe you did it Gina you're a
legend to the nine nine nine
Samuel
detective Peralta has made a caller in
the jewelry store Heights way to go
Jakey that's okay no he didn't get
sufficient evidence to make it stick so
we have the next 48 hours to fix his
mistake
what evidence did you have when you
arrested this guy
pretty Ironclad stuff
it's been a while mind if I ask you a
few questions well well well
if it isn't joke oralter that's it
you're interested
case closed Adrian what are you doing
here I'm an insurance investigator now I
thought you were in Alaska oh yeah I was
after Rosa and I broke up but then I
accidentally killed a protected Buffalo
self-defense next thing I know Fish and
Game are all over my ass I ended up in a
fight with a bear and I had to think to
myself why am I even here wait a minute
you fought a bear big time the trick on
that head butt him in the penis push him
over a cliff I bet that works with a lot
of animals only the male ones learned
that the hard way how's life as an
insurance investigator it's amazing at
Great star Mutual they let me do
whatever I want as long as I'm getting
that job done and you know I am last
week I water boarded a dude oh that's
not illegal doesn't matter I'm not a cop
anyway
[Music]
hahaha
hey
somebody finger down Scully hey chick
she's been alive forever how did you
stick your hangovers oh I didn't drink I
was however extremely into cocaine for
most of 1986. I got to tell you the
truth is the truth you and me man we're
going to be co-captants but first i'm
taking you to Japan I'm already packed I
had three heart attacks that you're in
declared bankruptcy
foreign